wir gehen direkt weiter zu Christian
Mölling Politikwissenschaftler und
Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik in
Berlin und auch Leiter des
programmsicherheit und Verteidigung
schön guten Abend hemeling
hallo gelernteile hemmeling ich möchte
mit einer user-frage einsteigen und die
knüpft an die Diskussion gerade an
Musculus latissimus dorsi so viel Zeit
muss sein fragt bei Youtube was könnte
es hi Yin Ping denn für Vorteile bringen
sich gegen Putin zu wenden
eben schon den Beitrag an von MRT bin
auch das
es für China um das schnelle Ende des
Konfliktes geht weil es zu Zeit die
Wirtschaft behindert und das ist
natürlich für China einen wichtiger
Faktor der da ist man macht sich
gleichzeitig aber ich will nicht sagen
unverzichtbar aber man macht sich
zumindest
man macht es sich einfach sich zwischen
Moskau und die USA zum Beispiel zu
stellen und zu zeigen guck mal wir
können auch kooperieren also man wird
auf einmal wieder ein interessanter
Kooperationspartner aus Sicht Pekings
muss ich auch das beste Welt wenn man
tatsächlich
Moskau für einen Zeit lang beiseite
schieben kann
matthesen hat auch gesagt dass er das
Treffen und auch die Inhalte als erste
Bewegung von China auch weg von Russland
sieht hin zum Westen hin zu den USA bei
dem Treffen wie würden sie das bewerten
das mag so sein da macht aber sicherlich
eine Schwalbe noch keinen Sommer also
das soll heißen dass ich hier jetzt
insgesamt die Politik zwischen Peking
und Moskau komplett verschiebt auf Dauer
da wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher
ich glaube da hängt es sehr stark davon
ab welche Vorteile mittelfristig China
noch in so einer Perspektive in so einer
in so einer Verbindung sieht es bedeutet
ja auch das sehen wir heute mal auf das
zu verschieben gesagt habe dass die
Schwäche moskau ist und diese
Abhängigkeit dazu führt dass Peking
international wichtiger wird viele haben
akzeptiert dass Peking eine Rolle in
diesem Konflikt spielt und diese Rolle
nutzt es aus das heißt also dieser
Isolierung Russlands hilft China im
Grunde genommen mit dieser Situation
warum sollte man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
darauf verzichten aber ich glaube dass
man das der taktisch spielen wird
also auch das war ja die die
Einschätzung und Einordnung ein kleiner
anfänglicher Schritt aber das muss
natürlich weiter beobachtet werden
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam auf folgende
Bilder hier schauen vom 16 September das
ist keine zwei Monate her da ist Putin
zu Gast auf dem Gipfel der Shanghai
Organisation für Zusammenarbeit in
Usbekistan und er war für das Treffen
vor allem ja eine Möglichkeit gesehen
Partnerschaften zu vertiefen vor zwei
Monaten allen voran mit China da ist er
eng an der Seite mit himping es ging
aber auch darum dass er mit Erdogan
gesprochen hat dem türkischen
Präsidenten dem indischen premiermodi
jetzt hören wir jetzt sagen auch sie das
mag so sein die wegbewegung Chinas von
Russland das sind sozusagen die
Anzeichen wenn das so kommen sollte
wer bleibt denn da noch als Verbündeter
Putins
ich glaube was von vor allen Dingen in
den Bildern sehen konnte ist bei solchen
Treffen gibt es immer ganz viele
bücherale Gespräch das wird doch jetzt
bei den G20-Treffen zu sein auch in dem
Treffen der Shania
kooperationsorganisation war es schon so
dass offensichtlich einige Akteure
insbesondere China Russland signalisiert
haben dass es auf einem falschen Weg ist
und dass man nicht möchte dass dieser
Weg fortgesetzt wird also diese
Isolation ist nicht Bali das erste Mal
auftaucht sondern was schon lange dort
angefangen hat für Russland werden die
Partner in der Tat weniger oder der
Bereich in dem man kooperieren kann wird
immer weniger den Russland das muss man
ja Aussehen aus der
Sicht von China brauchen sich das
Westens hat zwar eine geopolitische Lage
die interessant ist die relevant ist
nimmt aber als Bedeutung als Markt
insbesondere für zum Beispiel
chinesische Produkte oder Produkte
einfach ab das heißt also für China ist
auch die ökonomische Dimension Russlands
immer weniger bedeutsam interessant ist
aber das Russland lange Zeit lang ich
bin das dazu sagen politisch
militärische ökonomisch Kräfte in Europa
binden wird weil wir jetzt natürlich im
Wesentlichen erstmal darauf gucken wie
wird sich Russland in Zukunft verhalten
und das hemmt natürlich die Verteilung
der Ressourcen die die USA sehr gerne
von Europa hätte nämlich dass wir die
USA viel stärker mit Blick auf Asien und
China unterstützen würden also wir sehen
es schält sich immer stärker ein Dreieck
heraus
in dem Moskau sicherlich schwächer wird
aber auch diese Schwäche kann dazu
führen dass irgendjemand diesen Dreieck
wiederum stärker wird
was glauben Sie wie wird sich dieses
Dreieck in den kommenden Wochen Monaten
weiterentwickeln kann man das schon
prognostizieren
das kann man und man liegt damit
garantiert falsch deswegen will ich das
jetzt keinen Fall machen wir haben ja
gesehen wie
wie sprunghaft die kriegsverläufe sind
und es hängt in erheblichen Maßen davon
ab wie dieser Krieg zu Ende Gedicht wann
sondern wie er zu Ende geht was
tatsächlich an politischer Macht und
auch ein militärischer Macht in Moskau
tatsächlich verbleiben kann das muss man
glaube ich so klar sehen man kann sich
ganz unterschiedliches Szenarien
vorstellen dass eine ist die Möglichkeit
dass es tatsächlich einen
einen Waffenstillstand geht ich will
nicht von einem Frieden sprechen der
länger dauert und belastbarer ist als
die letzten die wir gehabt haben mit
Moskau also die Ukraine mit Moskau
gehabt hat es kann aber auch sein dass
es zu Nachfolge kämpfenden Moskau gibt
das sozusagen das komplett andere Extrem
das ist zum nachfolgekämpfen in Moskau
geht um die Position des Präsidenten und
man damit eine große Instabilität und
bis hin zu einer teilweisen Stillstand
oder ein Zusammenbrechen der staatlichen
Funktion
möglicherweise sich denken also sie
sehen da ist viel Spiel drin deswegen
ist es sehr schwierig da jetzt oder sehr
gewagt da eine steile These nach vorne
zu stellen ja absolut sehr viel Dynamik
auch drin bleiben wir bei einem Aspekt
von denen sie sagen dass sie es für
unwahrscheinlich halten oder auch nicht
sagen wollen dass man jetzt direkt von
einem Frieden sprechen kann Präsident
selenski hat ja heute noch mal in der
Region betont wir sind bereit für
Frieden aber für einen Frieden unter
unseren Bedingungen unsere
Korrespondentin Moskau hat gesagt dass
da auch schon das Väter und Dementi
prompt aus Moskau gefolgt ist also mich
würde aber trotzdem noch mal ihre
Erklärung interessieren warum sie das
friedensszenario als unwahrscheinlich
einschätzen
naja wir haben zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
eigentlich aus der ukrainischen Sicht
keinen Grund in Verhandlung einzustimmen
weil man militärisch noch im
in der Offensive ist und man tatsächlich
noch Räume gewinnen kann wir erinnern
uns zurück vor zwei Wochen hätte man vor
zwei Wochen verhandelt und wir sollten
immer fahren oder die Ukraine sollte
immer verhandeln dann der kerson nicht
befreit worden so das wäre vielleicht
Teil eines the greements geworden oder
auch nicht dann hätte tatsächlich dann
wäre diese diese Gegend nicht befreit
worden noch ist die Ukraine in der Lage
Land zurück zu gewinnen das heißt aus
deren Sicht macht seit keinen Sinn zu
verhandeln und der wichtigste Punkt ist
es gibt relativ wenig Hoffnung dass was
auch immer als Verhandlungsergebnis beim
waffenstillen rauskäme das belastbar
wäre denn diesen waffenschüssel hat es
ja schon gegeben wir haben 2014 eine
Waffenstillstand zwischen der Ukraine
und Russland gehabt der ist aber immer
wieder gebrochen worden das sind mehr
Menschen gestorben innerhalb in der Zeit
des Waffenstillstands als vor dieser
auseinander als vor dem als vor dem
Waffenstillstand das heißt das Vertrauen
in Moskau dass ein solcher Vertrag
eingehalten wird und nicht dazu genutzt
wird um einfach eine Zeit zu gewinnen um
seine militärischen Kräfte wieder
aufzubauen dieses Vertrauen ist im
besten Falle gering wenn gar nicht
vorhanden es gibt auch keinen Grund
dieses Vertrauen zu haben
da kommt auch eine passende user-frage
rein von thompas Trump bei Youtube er
geht auch in dieselbe Richtung und sagt
bei Friedensverhandlungen kommen niemals
die Maximalforderung einer Seite raus
außer es wird eine Kapitulation
erzwungen wie sieht das ist seine Frage
ein Kompromiss aus ihrer Sicht aus
eine zu schwer zu skizzieren der
Kompromiss bedeutet ja dass beide Seiten
sich auch etwas verständigen können was
sie dann auch wovon sie auch glauben
dass jeweils der andere ist einhält das
ist glaube ich der Kompromiss und der
Kompromiss muss jeweils zu Hause
vertretbar sein auch das gehört mit dazu
ich muss das Zuhause meinen meinen
Menschen erklären können dass ich diesen
Kompromiss eingegangen bin und wir haben
ja gerade deswegen ein Krieg weil wir
und weil es um etwas geht was nicht
verhandelbar oder was nicht teilbar ist
nämlich ein Gebiet und die Menschen die
darauf wohnen von daher sehe ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nur sehr schwer einen
kompromissing zumindest kein Kompromiss
der bedeuten würde
dass die Ukraine Territorium abgibt aber
das muss man noch mal ganz klar sagen
hängt von der Lage auf dem Gefechtsfeld
ab die Verhandlungsbereitschaft der
beiden Akteure sowohl Moskau als auch
hier verändert sich immer wieder in
Abhängigkeit von der militärischen Lage
das heißt das Militär das politische
spielen immer wieder zusammen das heißt
auch das Verhandlung und das Führen von
Krieg nicht getrennt voneinander zu
sehen sind sondern sie bedingen sich
gegenseitig
bleiben wir dann ganz kurz bei der
militärischen Lage auch wenn die
Prognose immer schwierig ist aber was
sind ihre aktuellen Informationen
darüber was man erahnen kann wie sich
die militärische Lage in den kommenden
Wintermonaten entwickeln wird also
nachdem die Ukraine ja bei ressene Pro
vorgedrungen ist wird ja jetzt vor allem
im Osten gekämpft aber was glauben Sie
wie wird das jetzt in den kommenden
Wintermonaten weitergehen
also die Ukraine hat militärisch und
politisch gute Gründe diesen Krieg auf
alle Fälle weiterzuführen wir haben ja
zurzeit auf relativ viel Diskussionen
darum dass der Winter diesen Krieg zum
Stillstand bringen würde ich glaube
nicht dass das passiert warum nicht weil
man auf der einen Seite militärisch
jetzt noch sozusagen den den Impuls
nutzen kann man hat auch die
Unterstützung zu Hause es ist also
möglich weiter zu kämpfen es ist
wahrscheinlich auch notwendig weiter zu
kämpfen denn wenn die Diskussionen über
diesen Krieg weitergehen sowie zurzeit
dann wenn wir wieder viel Diskussion
über Verhandlungen haben und dass man
doch im Winter nicht kämpfen kann und
dass man auch im Grunde um jetzt den
Krieg nicht auf militärischen auch
politisch einfrieren müsste und die
Ukraine wird sich dringend bemüht sehen
gegen diese Ideen die dann bei uns in
den Medien zirkulieren andere Bilder zu
senden das heißt also Bilder davon dass
der Krieg weitergeht damit diese
Diskussion eigentlich keinen empirische
Grundlage hat das heißt es gibt
militärische Gründe als auch politische
Gründe für Kiew weiter zu kämpfen um
Gelände weiterhin zu gewinnen um Moskau
auch keine Atempause zu zu gestehen denn
ansonsten könnte Moskau sich neu
formulieren aber auch politisch mit
Blick auf die Unterstützung des Westens
die wahrscheinlich zurückgehen würde
oder aber zum Schlüchtern kommen würde
wenn es keine positiven Meldungen mehr
über den Fortgang des Krieges in der
Ukraine geben würde danke Ihnen für
diese Einschätzung zwei Aspekte zum
Abschluss unseres Gesprächs einer der
geht etwas zurück aber es ist eine
user-frage die ich Ihnen natürlich nicht
vorenthalten möchte die geht noch mal
auf das Dreieck was Sie beschrieben
haben ein in Bezug auf USA China und
Russland die Frage kommt von will Erys
bei Youtube er fragt wo ist Europa in
diesem Dreieck
bestimmt Europa habe ich jetzt an dem
Punkt rausgelassen weil es sozusagen
dieses Spannungsverhalten Europa spielt
natürlich eine Rolle in den Zusammenhang
wir sind ein enger Partner der USA wir
sind aber nicht die USA
aber wir sehen ja schon dass in dem was
ich hier gerade raus bildet nämlich
tatsächlich eine eine systemische
Konfrontation also eine Konfrontation
zwischen politischen Systemen und damit
auch sozusagen weltanschaulichen
Systemen aber auch eine
Konfrontation auf unterschiedlichen
Politikfelder oder Problemfälle also die
Ökonomie das militärische aber auch das
politische
dass da Europa eine wesentliche Rolle
spielt und den USA sicherlich deutlich
näher steht als China oder Russland das
heißt also ja man kann dieses Dreieck
auch zu einem Viereck machen und dann
spielt Europa darin eine Rolle das ist
ein sehr einfaches Bild was ich hier
benutzt habe also von daher der gehört
Europa sicherlich mit rein ich würde es
allerdings nicht so einfach und
wunderbar wieder in einen alten Westen
transferieren weil das sicherlich eine
eine Rhetorik aus der Vergangenheit ist
ich glaube Europa dass das Verhältnis
das französische Verhältnis sich in den
nächsten Jahren einfach noch neu
definieren wird auch abhängig davon wer
in den USA aber auch in Europa in den
nächsten Jahren den Schulen gibt
und unsere Userinnen und User sie
kommentieren fleißig weiter und stellen
noch eine interessante Frage von hoher
bei Youtube geht jetzt wieder in Bezug
auf dem militärischen Kriegsverlauf und
auch auf den Blick aufs Ende was müsste
sich da Fraktur für Russland signifikant
ändern damit man ein Ende des Kriegs aus
deren sich zumindest für günstiger
halten kann
ja das kann man jetzt sag mal
theoretisch oder generisch beantworten
die Kosten die eine spätere
Verhandlungslösung bedeutet die müssten
deutlich höher sein als sie jetzigen
Kosten zu jetzigen Zeitpunkt ist es so
dass Putin ein schlecht geführter Krieg
immer noch mehr hilft als ein schlechter
Frieden das ist bitter das ist aber so
warum
ich finde es ganz einfach versuchen in
dem Augenblick indem sie sagen okay wir
machen jetzt einen Waffenstillstand dann
ist im Grunde um so etwas wie Tag der
Abrechnung oder Zahltag dann wird
geguckt was hat denn jeder eigentlich
und da steht hier eigentlich zur
Verhandlung und in dem Augenblick würde
deutlich werden dass Moskau sein Blatt
komplett überreizt hat man hat diese
vier Gebiete annektiert die jetzt
eigentlich formal aus russischer Sicht
russisches Gebiet sind man verliert aber
jeden Tag Boden auf diesem Gebieten das
heißt also das politische Überleben des
Präsidenten würde in dem Augenblick in
dem Zahltag wäre wahrscheinlich deutlich
unwahrscheinlicher sein dass er das
überlebt
als das als wenn er diesen Krieg einfach
am Laufen hält und wir sehen dass das
russische Regime dynisch ist gegenüber
Menschen dass es bereit ist jederzeit zu
lügen und es bereitet Menschen
tausendfach auch wenn sie schlecht
ausgebildet sind in den Krieg zu
schicken was ich damit meine sind die
die Soldaten Soldaten die
teilmobilisiert worden sind das heißt
also hier ist nicht damit zu rechnen
dass in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein
Frieden zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
tatsächlich für Moskau interessant ist
auf der anderen Seite wird Kiew
wahrscheinlich viel von dem was es an
jetzt an Gebieten gewonnen hat nicht
einfach so wieder abgeben auch Kiew hat
gezeigt dass es militärisch nicht
einfach zu besiegen ist
danke dafür für ihre Einordnungen zu
diesem menschenverachten russischen
Angriffskrieg und auch den Erklärungen
mit Blick auf die Szenarien eine
Abschlussfrage die bezieht sich von mir
noch mal auf den G20-Gipfel in den
kommenden Tagen das Treffen heute einen
Tag vor dem offiziellen Start zwischen
he und beiden was erwarten sie aber vom
G20 Gipfel generell
ich glaube da geht 20 Gipfel ist die
Möglichkeit
höher insbesondere für den für die
Bundeskanzler
zu gucken in welche Richtung er ganz
gerne das deutsche Netzwerk die
deutschen Verbindungen eigentlich
spannen spannen will er war gerade zuvor
in Peking hat auch vor seiner Reise klar
gemacht dass er die Abhängigkeiten die
Deutschland hat diversifizieren will
also es geht nicht darum Deutschland
abzukappen sondern aber diese strenge
die man hat im Grunde genommen über
viele unterschiedliche Schultern zu
verteilen so dass man nicht von einem
Akteur so stark abhängig ist wie wir das
zurzeit von Russland sind aber auch von
China sind und ich glaube das ist eine
der vielen Möglichkeiten ist die der
Bundeskanzler nutzen wird um tatsächlich
dieses Netzwerk weiter zu spinnen das
zeigt ja auch dass diese Reise die er in
die Region macht die macht er nicht nur
nach Bali zum G20 Gipfel sondern hat sie
jetzt ja schon genutzt um in der Region
klar zu machen dass Deutschland offen
ist für mehr und neue Kooperationen
Wirtschaftsbereich und ich erwarte dass
das tatsächlich
etwas ist wo man einen weiteren Baustein
in dem Umbau der deutschen
Außenwirtschaftspolitik sehen wird
Erwartungen und Aussagen von Christian
Mölling Politikwissenschaftler und
Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik in
Berlin vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit hier
bei ZDF